the Duke of courland once sailed the
Baltic Sea on a ship like this one
this is a reconstruction of the 17th
century schooner and it remains faithful
to the original design
it's a dream come true for Captain
Anatoly malecon of
he previously used it for fishing trips
but now takes tourists out to sea
the blush that was Sweden and this was
coral and yeah guess the quarry on ski
lifts leduc of courland was a shrewd
businessman but no setup companies and
factories breezewood by III to the wavy
edges beyond three shipyards for the
construction of both trade and military
vessels you are unique go buddy really
he also had three masted ships with a
hundred cannon that even the English
were scared of his chase get to pay
everybody
it's an adventure for holidaymakers even
if they're sailing trip only lasts a few
hours
the shot can be heard in the resort town
of your mala la fiaz answer to the
French Riviera it first attracted
tourists over 200 years ago the sandy
beach stretches for over 30 kilometers
your mother soon became a meeting point
for artists intellectuals and famous
people gurgaon a splash of elizabeth
when people ask me who's been here i
always say it's easier to list those who
haven't searched discussion near build
the town owes much of its charm to its
wooden architecture over 400 of the
houses are listed
while many have been renovated some are
still in need of attention they vary
greatly in terms of size and style dr.
bill of Mordovia repeat or whatever was
in fashion in Europe at the time was
reflected in the architecture of these
summer houses in your mala not far from
your mala is kimary famous for its
sulphur springs and healing mud baths
there used to be sanatoriums here but
the infrastructure collapsed with the
Soviet Union the hot springs form in the
high moorland of camry national park
where visitors can take a three
kilometer walk to get closer to nature
agnes Valentina has been a ranger here
for four years the fauna and flora of a
raised bog is not very diverse but you
don't find anywhere else you can also
see some pines but it never grows as big
as a normal pine in the forest because
it grows on this acid water so these
pines some of them are more than 100 or
even 200 years old your mullahs open-air
museum is testimony to the Latvian love
of nature once a week visitors are
invited to sample home smoked fish the
tradition is also upheld in many of the
local villages
us now on principle we mainly get
tourists from russia belarus ukraine and
so on but german tourists also come on
the cruise ships recorded please
nicaragua come back in the town centre
come evening after long days on the
beach or in the thick of nature urmila
fills with people looking for good food
and entertainment and they don't have to
look very far because the Latvian
Riviera has it all